if there's one Banner lesson I've
learned in my career it's that you need
to focus and focus stands for follow one
course until successful this might be
the biggest mistake that creators and
entrepreneurs and the ambitious make
overall too many social media platforms
too many projects too many YouTube
channels too many ideas not enough
execution on one thing if you're
multi-passionate and you want to do
multiple YouTube channels I want to
challenge you what is the strongest one
which one are you most passionate about
out most proficient at and also has the
best opportunity of producing an income
and money so make a plan work the plan K
distractions and protect your focus